i love this struggle i think that this
is materially important for people to
examine their life and say what am i
doing am i living in alignment with my
capabilities am i truly front loading
and investing in the skills for this
small 80 to 100 years that i have here
on this planet am i maximizing the way
that i would love to live
michael gervais welcome the show
uh stoked to be here with you chris
thank you
am i right in saying that you worked
with felix baumgartner you are right
that
red bull stratos thing
was one of the most inspiring
periods that i think i've ever seen can
you tell people the story how you got
working with them and and what happened
throughout that process
it was
it's one of the most meaningful projects
i've ever been on so we can start by
just level setting that
i think for everybody that was involved
in this project it was
life impacting and so
the origin story was um i was
part of the red bull high performance
program that was being built out at that
time and we're probably about three four
years into it
and uh i got tapped by the head of high
performance andy walsh and um so he
tapped me on the shoulder he's like hey
you know the red bull stratus program
was it's come to a halt
so what do you mean
and he says
yeah you know like we've been at this
thing like three and a half years
and uh
felix can't
continue
what do you mean well he cried and i'm
not sharing anything chris that's not
public okay so let's be very clear about
that but felix is in the airport airport
and he's like totally broken down that
he can't handle
um moving forward because he's he's just
terrified
well it makes sense you know he was
none of the
none of the teammates were investing in
his internal capabilities and so this is
a project that's never been done before
uh
hardened crusty
old dogs that you know really have been
around as test pilots and
um
aerospace engineers and like just a
hardened crew
and they built the capsules the
technology they had the strategy dialed
in they had everything like to nails
and then when it came to the internal
capabilities
what had taken place is that he
you know raised his arms like two years
in like hey my chest feels tight i'm
breathing kind of funny when i'm in the
suit and so the suit is a special
customized suit from nasa that actually
i don't know if it was from nasa but it
was a specialized suit there was two of
them they're about two million dollars
each
and um i just felt tight so they said oh
okay we'll see if we can make some
modifications in the suit so right we go
to tech and kit first
uh he waves his arms again
about two and a half years in and goes
still i'm breathing funny when i'm in
the suit and they go right let's get
your fitness up
and so
um
he was doing all the right fitness stuff
and he's like this isn't it like i'm fit
and then so he comes back and he's like
right uh i can't do this anymore like
i'm terrified
and so that's when they brought me in
and so
you know he had developed quote unquote
claustrophobia
and as adults we don't just develop
claustrophobia but he had developed that
and
they bring me in because this xx
millions of dollars project
brightest minds in aerospace team
four years in of these mines and this
money
were now at a screeching halt because we
lacked the
internal skills of the
person the only person that was going to
go to 130 000 feet and jump from the
edge of space when the brightest minds
in aerospace were not sure if he passed
through a double sonic boom because he
was definitely well most likely going to
do the speed of sound
that his arms and legs would rip off
and so
work out why he would be
concerned i have no idea why he would be
worried
so
uh so that's where they tap my shoulder
like hey you want to get involved i was
like wait let me get this right um the
brightest minds in aerospace weren't
sure and yes and he's terrified yes and
there's a lot of pressure a lot of money
on the line correct
yeah i'm in like this sounds perfect and
i say that glibly but you know it's as
simple as
applying good science
is where
my
craft begins and ends and so the craft
of high performance psychology has
really anchored in
the story traditions of science and
laboratories that are that require um
some noodling to make that laboratory
science come to life in real world and
certainly in high-stakes environments
and so that's where i entered the
picture and we just worked from the
inside out
and um invested in that part of his
capabilities and made some significant
um
investments and the rest you know the
rest is history as they say can you go
through any of the techniques that you
used with him
yeah there's a documentary it was a
recreation documentary that espn plus
did where we did it was basically he and
i going through the work that we did it
was really cool it was one of the first
things on espn plus
um
i can't remember the name of the name of
the show but it was really good and a
lot of this stuff is in there but the
the essence of it is
uh systematic desensitization
flooding is also um a more common term
in psychology
and so it's taking systematically
the
um the acute stressor the thing that you
have some sort of fear or panic over
and then working backwards to be able to
bite size digest or metabolizing the
smallest amount of fear relative to that
panic
and then laddering up laddering up
laddering up
and the way we do that is first you
figure out what the thing is that
somebody's afraid of
and in this case we couldn't work from a
managing fear we had to work from
extinguishing fear which is a totally
different ballgame right
here well managing fear is like i'm
working with it but
in that level of hostility we need to
extinguish it so that he knows that he
has completely worked
he okay i'll take it in other terms like
managing the fear of holding a snake if
a snake is the thing versus like no no
listen i'm good with the snake so that's
what extinguishing the fear looks like
in more pedestrian language or example
and so we had to work from that place
and so
first you work in your imagination and
then you work in low stress environments
and then you work in
uh rugged and then you work up into
hostile
and so the way that we did that was
imagination then uh the suit alone on
the ground then the suit in the capsule
on the ground having to manage the
oxygen
um gas exchange because if you get that
exchange wrong while you're in the suit
in a capsule on ground that's one thing
you open the door but if you're up above
a couple thousand feet we got problems
and he was 130 000 feet and then we did
it in a pressurized capsule
where um
it's it's it's not the real thing it's
still rubber bullets but um stakes are
higher stakes are higher you know
for a lot of reasons and so we just
gated that um and the best part of the
story chris was like uh the crusty old
dogs you know like god love them they
were sitting around a table when i first
got introduced to the team
and um
they're looking at me and they're sizing
every part of me up
and then one of the old dogs kind of
kind of pushes his chair back and he
goes
okay dr gervais no disrespect and i'm
going okay here comes the disrespect
right and he's and he looks and he goes
i've been doing this a long time
never seen anybody come back from this
no disrespect but we are not gonna have
blood on our hands
and so i don't know what you're gonna
do what you think you're gonna be able
to do to convince him
and i was like okay
um but the stakes are way too high and
i'm not into it
and then so you look around the table
and there's like six other
again legends in the field of
pilot testing and aerospace like not in
their head like yup that's right
and so i go yeah me too
and they're like well what are you gonna
do i said well what do you need to see
for you
to know that he has the capabilities
and they they said it he needs to be he
can't he can't be in this suit for more
than 30 minutes
without like hitting the panic button he
needs to be in it up in space near space
for six and a half hours up to six and a
half hours
so we gotta see that
great no problem all right sounds like a
reasonable goal let's go to work
and so um
if we couldn't do it
you know on land for six and a half
hours why would anyone else want to send
them up into you know the hostile
environment of
the edges of space so that was the that
was the mission
um
and this is not a stunt this was
something that actually had the reason
bright minds in aerospace were invested
is because
if we are going to get off this planet
if we need to
that we need to also understand what
happens to the human body if we need to
press the eject button at around a
hundred twenty hundred thirty hundred
forty thousand feet
can the human body withstand that type
of free fall
and so the answer is yes and no but we
needed to understand that
um for the future
of space travel
rory sutherland vice chairman of ogilvy
advertising he says silicon valley sees
everything as an optimization problem
what he means is that
when you're looking at
reducing the number of passenger
complaints during security at london
heathrow they were talking about how can
we narrow the aisles and speed up the
number of security checkers and rory
came in and just added 30 minutes from
here 45 minutes from here 60 minutes
from here wait things and it
90 of the complaints went away what i'm
seeing
similarly in your situation was that
a lot of the engineering problems were
focused on first
and the inner workings the the human
psychology side of felix was kind of
left to be
spit and sawdusted into operation right
like grit your teeth and we'll get
through it type thing and i think that
it's a really the reason i wanted to
hear about this story is it does feel
like the meshing of two worlds at around
about the time that this is happening as
well right you know a spot like rugby
which now is a full-on
professional sport
only 20 years ago when england won the
world cup the first time uh that the
guys would have jobs on the side
these dudes wouldn't be full-time in
rugby and if they were full-time they'd
be drinking they'd be going out partying
so yeah to see old world clashing with
new uh i think we're seeing this in
marketing and advertising in consumer
behavior and behavioral economics in
sports psychology performance music all
this stuff
and you're right on the money is that
the idea is that
um that i was nodding too early that you
picked up on is that
for whatever reason
when we're thinking about high
performance
the people who set that table it was set
40 years ago
and the avant-garde coaches and you know
principals were like yeah psychology is
important but um
put that at the end of the table for
right now like we'll keep a chair there
but you know and those are the
progressives
and they were curious to have good
conversations about the psychology of
the performers but never implemented in
a systemic way
and now what we're seeing is that chair
is sitting like right next to the head
coach or gm or president vice president
ceo in meaningful ways about okay
our
the thing that makes us
special is the way that we work
it's not necessarily the widget when
we're talking about human capabilities
and human potential whether it's big
business or big sport it's the it's the
humanness of it
and the ingenuity that comes from that
so
that doesn't lab yes the environment's
really important there's two ways we
work inside out and outside in and if
we're over indexing on outside in
technology
you know
environmental conditions which are all
really important but not
watering or hydrating from the inside
out those companies that do that
massive they've got the competitive
advantage right this is this is the
beautiful thing about looking at a sport
or
um having a
a chart in music you know you can see
the outcomes are there the people that
have the best um
performance based on their preparation
are the ones that are going to perform
the best when it comes to game day
that's exactly it yeah and whether it's
sport or business um and right now it's
really fun to take a look at what's
happening as from this lenses is that
the great resignation is basically
people saying i'm not working like this
anymore are you kidding me like i i
don't know my kids you know because i'm
working
eight to ten every day and i'm trying to
cram in a few hours a few few minutes
for dinner and wake up and drop off and
tucking in and like no
i'm not doing this anymore
and
that resignation is basically hand
waving to say there's a better way to do
life
and
the leaders of company and the leaders
of sport that are able to say
wait a minute
um
the extraction model is busted
let's get into the unlocking business
and that's where i'm placing my efforts
is to you know
people are saying no no i can't give
anymore i'm tired
i'm fatigued my stress level is beyond
and i'm working my ass off for this
thing but i need i need some kind of
reprieve and then what happens next year
is like new in sport teams it's like
younger athletes more interesting
contracts happening in business it's um
you know we got a 20 growth arc you know
year after year it's like wait a minute
and so which is all good i mean those
things are really part of the
competitive landscape and if you don't
invest
we call it front loading if you don't
front load the psychological skills
those stressors happen the demands of
the moment take place and people go i i
actually don't have
the goods to stay the long game here
i find it very interesting someone asked
me a question the other day about about
front loading discomfort and working out
what your tolerances are and jordan
peterson had the same insight that
working out how hard you can work in
your 20s is a great way to be able to
determine your capacity later through
life because it's almost like you've
pushed your limits so hard that you know
where the sweet spot is but it's still
sometimes difficult for people to work
out whether they are
slowing down because they're leaving
something on the table and they're
selling themselves short or whether
they're slowing down because they're
genuinely close to burnout how do you
advise the people that you work with to
distinguish between the two leaving it
on the table and selling themselves
short or
dude you're you're nearly about to have
a breakdown you you need to back off the
gas
i think it's just an it's both of those
and one more that i'll add which is
most
there's like 15 things i want to say to
you but most most people do not have an
accurate understanding
of what the edges and staying at the
edges feel like
so that deep nauseatedly focused effort
and attention
at the edge and and being able to stay
there
for longer than you thought possible is
how we build capacity psychological
physiological spirituality
and so
most people don't have
that understanding because one it's
overwhelming
and two it is exhausting and so in this
conservation of energy
we know that the edge is where we want
to get to but we're not sure how much
other expenditure we're going to have on
ourselves throughout the day or the
years so we play it safe and small
and so to to the earlier insight about
the 20s is where you go to the edge i
would say yeah i like that idea
however
it's when you get this
right which is run to the edge stay
there longer than you thought possible
that you could and by the way people can
do a lot more
like honestly people can do a lot more
than they think
and then you recover intelligently
and in that running to the edge and
recovering intelligently
there's there's a physics to that that
we can talk about every unit of stress
for unit of recovery but where the
physics breaks down and this is why i
love psychology the beautiful science of
psychology is that it's invisible
and when we run to the edge and we're
returning to high ground for recovery
the
the amount of
energy that is spent on
maladaptive or
uh
thinking patterns that don't
create vibrancy is a problem so it's
like we're running
we're running to and recovering from
with a leaky bucket but when we invest
in our psychology not only just to dance
at the edge of stress
but
the climb there and the retreat back we
need that bucket to be rock solid so
what am i saying the way that you think
matters
and unless you do a deep investigation
in how you think and how you feel and
how thoughts and emotions work together
it just gets really
tiring
and because it's the leaky bucket
experience and so that's where i get
really excited about this beautiful
science of
psychology for sure what does that look
like in practice someone coming back to
the recovery appropriately
well the the physics of it like what
what are the
activities of recovery or the the
returning back
their thinking patterns
yeah yeah so um
it's as simple as god that was great you
know like holy [ __ ] i did some stuff
today now i can't wait you know like i'm
one step closer to being the human i
want to be and this is this is flat out
this is what i'm doing you know it's so
it's like mapping
your thinking patterns and those are
just
squibby little examples but it's
matching your thinking pattern with your
purpose and the vision that you hold for
yourself
and then and then if you can have
clarity of your guiding principles
your first principles in life your
philosophy if you will and i'm not
throwing around words sloppily purpose
philosophy and vision are materially
important and separate ideas
and
if you can have those three
held close to the heartbeat of who you
are and you're nurturing those with
every micro decision you have
oh man i mean that's the type of
alignment
that
creates the flywheel that most people
are looking for
why do you think it's important to have
a personal philosophy
it's the guiding principles so personal
philosophy is that simple it's like what
are your first principles in life
and
it is the way that
when you're clear about it and i can
give you a couple examples in a minute
when you're clear about it choices and
microchoices become clear
and so here's a
here's
let's do
dr martin luther king jr
okay let's we could do gandhi we could
do
mother teresa we could do helen keller
we could go on and on with examples
let's do dr king though is that we know
his philosophy
because every room he went into
his thoughts
his words that he would use to express
those first principles his thoughts and
his actions were lined up
towards
equality
justice for all
and it would be a surprise if that
wasn't what he was going to talk about
at dinner
and so
that that mechanism is that he had
clarity
and that's why there's no rival there is
there's no competitor
for introspection there's no competition
when it comes to
the
investigation and sometimes the
interrogation
to look deeply within
and become clear about first principles
and once you know those first principles
and you can hold them close to the
heartbeat close to the sun of you know
your essence then then the choices that
you make become so much easier
and you'd
it's not like you don't wander off you
know make some wild choices and mistakes
or whatever and like lose your way from
time to time
but there's something to bounce up
against
and for a long time that's what religion
held for many people
it's what
the aaa community holds for people
and it's also something that we can each
do as a family we can each do as an
organization and we can each do as an
individual
what are your first principles and if
you don't know him comments
and i'm competing against you
i love it that's great
let me take out the deep water you just
don't know you're about to get drowned
right because you don't know your first
principles you're going to be flailing
your arms with the stressors that come
from the deep water
people that know like hey
deep water is where i find myself like
deep waters where i go like that's what
we're trying to do here but i'm going to
do it in this way
i'm not going to grab your ankles and
hold you under water that's not how i'm
going to do the deep waters but i'm
going to swim next to you faster than
maybe you think
you know like i'm being silly here but
like that's the idea
of um of knowing your first principles
practically how would people develop
their first principles and their
philosophy go to work no one can do it
for you
right like this might be a meditation
process it might be a written down
process but you've got to get it out of
your head for the most part so nobody
can do this work for you um when you
know it you know it
and so
my challenge to folks that i work with
is like start with pages then get it
down to 25 words then whittle it down to
maybe just a handful of words or a
sentence
um
i mean jesus got it down to a word right
love
buddha got it down to loving-kindness
okay those are pretty cool
dr king got it down pretty simply right
justice you know i mean
equality
like what
it's not that complicated like what do
you stand for and then your purpose
bounces off of that
and we know the science of purpose right
i'm sure you and your community are
really clear in the science of purpose
just how powerful that is
but you can't make this stuff up you
can't borrow somebody else's purpose you
can't borrow
somebody else's philosophy you might be
inspired by it and go oh my god i love
that
and then it's got to become metabolized
for it to be yours
and then you become the animation of
that and when you are the animation of
that everywhere you go you become one of
the most powerful people on the planet
because most people don't do it most
people are not true the
the tuning fork is not accurate
it's off pitch because what most people
are doing chris is that they are looking
to the outside world for confirmation of
the their internal experience in life
so they're outsourcing
am i okay
what do you think does that seem okay
does this look okay
are we okay
you know it's this constant
mechanic not mechanic but mechanistic
way of seeing if you're okay is checking
into the micro expressions and the body
language of others
speaking of that you work with some very
high profile performers a musician whose
show makes millions of dollars a night
or top flight athletes going for world
championships and medals and stuff
how do you advise them to deal with the
pressure of other people's expectations
and opinions because we all feel this
but we're now talking about
the people that feel this
as much as it's probably possible to
feel this
well we're working to dissolve it we're
working to dissolve pressure and kind of
change that game
and so
pressure for most people is the
experience of
i need to think or do faster than i
think i can do
you know and it's kind of that simple
it's like this
walls closing in around me whether it's
mental emotional and physical
and so there are
ways that when you invest in your
psychology you can dissolve pressure it
doesn't mean you're going to dissolve it
and extinguish it like we were talking
about that particular fear earlier
but it is possible to do that work so
um how do you do that you become
very familiar with how your thoughts and
emotions work together
and
i have asked this question
thousands of times the nfl draft picks
to
just about
you know every guest on the finding
mastery podcast is where does pressure
come from
and world's best hands down over and
over again say the same thing
from within
okay
you know so then how do we how do we
create an internal structure that you're
working to master
that and most people say i like
intensity
i like the way it feels to be on the
edge
but sometimes it gets the best of me
oh okay so we're not actually trying to
like remove stress from your life we're
actually trying to amplify it
purposefully and have all the internal
skills
to map up against it so that you can get
free
you can play you know you have the space
the internal space
to be able to
um
eloquently adjust on the razor's edge of
something that is
consequential or rugged or
you know
pressures is um is a bit of a luxury as
we've come to learn so
being able to eloquently adjust in those
environments is really cool that's the
mark of mastery
one of the things that i see a lot
patterns that people tell me about is
that as they're growing as they're
developing they start to feel more
lonely so a lot of self-work and
personal development is done in solitude
and it takes you further away from the
thought patterns which help you to
connect with the people that you used to
know as well
what's your insight there what's your
advice to people that are struggling
with that loneliness as they start to
level themselves up as they start to go
further you got it
you're on it there's a dark side
to
high performance there's a dark side to
exploring your potential there's a dark
side to mastery
i feel like we're not quite ready as a
community to completely talk about that
but um loneliness is one of those tenets
and
it doesn't mean it's bad
it doesn't necessarily mean that it can
be
as the dark side but there's a yin and
yang
to
all experiences in life if you can
pull way up and see the perspective but
how do you expect people to relate if
you're the only person that is submitted
everest like how how do you how i mean
there's a lack of words to describe
those colors that you saw and the smells
that you experience and that level of
feared fatigue and so here's the
loneliness is a is a problem but what
happens to most people
is that they come from their summit you
know
and they return back to the
average because they want to be part of
something
and so it's that inner
struggle
it's a civil war do i go back to the
summit and be alone
and have that sense of isolation
or do i stay here in the comfort of my
loved ones
and yes physically there's the metaphor
that will hold up
but more importantly it's emotionally
and mentally
and so
i love this struggle
i think that this is materially
important for people to examine their
life and say
what am i doing
am i living in alignment
with my capabilities am i truly front
loading and investing in the skills
for
this small
80 to 100 years that i have here on this
planet am i maximizing the way that i i
would love to live
and
we haven't touched a surface yet we
haven't really scratched it there's so
much more to go it's so
but you have to be willing to touch the
dark side
and um
know how to stay in it
longer than you thought possible
what are some of the other prices that
people pay
that we might not know about
yeah there's an agitation and a
scratchiness
there's a loneliness like we talked
about there is a um
there's a an expensive part of it
because not everyone
grieves financial rewards to be able to
be an explorer of themselves or or the
edges of the human experience
there is a an agitation that comes with
it because it's hard to solve it
it's like weaving a tapestry
and i don't think it's a puzzle because
the puzzle suggests that like there's
borders and edges
but it's more like a tapestry that's
being
sometimes scrapped together and
sometimes thoughtfully put together that
is materially important and so that's
hard to do
there's a
resourcefulness required
that other people may have not been able
to see how to pull
ideas and people and and
structures together
so there's um there's a lonely work and
an aloneness those are two separate
things and nobody does the extraordinary
alone
so there isn't aloneness there is a
loneliness
but it's too complicated we need each
other and i'm talking about human
flourishing in whatever capacity that
you might
use your imagination could be sport
business family whatever
is that
to align people
in in the unique way to create that two
plus two is
22 not four that that to be able to do
that
is hard
because you've got to
open up
literally open up the um mechanisms that
most people work from which is safety
you got to open that up and when you do
that
it's it's amazing but
those are some of the difficult you know
and then you've got time constraints
money constraints you've got other
constraints that are
normal for all of us you've got risk and
rules and so on and so on one of the
main tensions that i keep on seeing at
the moment is between
a
fear of insufficiency being used as a
driver and a desire for more being used
as a driver
filling the whole the void with
accomplishments uh and that can it's
really
it's it's nefarious right because
it still can be an intrinsic reward it
can still be an intrinsic driver it's
not necessarily something that you're
getting from other people but it's
driven by a fear of insufficiency as
opposed to a desire to maximize yourself
and this is a conversation that i keep
on having with people that i know that
are high performers that if you dig down
deep enough there is a kernel
of
running away from something that they
fear as well as running towards
something that they want and the um
relative ratio of those two
and oftentimes is a huge
indicator of their quality of life and
how much they enjoy their pursuits
very cool because
in there's two things when you say that
that resonate
one is
in 1980 1990 early 2000s it was about
you know being your best but that you
know self-help industry but
the thought wasn't completed
it's for what reason
what reason are you investing in you
so that you can help others
do the same
and so it's your best so that you can be
a um
you can create a rising tide for others
and so that's where we start to get into
the
uh
the more ancient and forward thinking at
the same time parts of humanity it's
it's to create the rising tide and then
the other piece that when you mention
that
is that
i think
it's going to sound really simple
but it's the relationship you have with
experience
that's at the center of this whole thing
of life it's the relationship that you
have with experience
and so it's nothing outside of you
changes you
it's only the way that you work with
that experience your relationship with
it and your relationship with it is met
by the quality of your philosophy your
unique philosophy by the the quality of
your internal psychological skills
and
we haven't we haven't invested here yet
as a nation as a as a humanity really we
have not invested properly here so the
relationship with experience is
materially important
um
when we want to oversimplify what we're
trying to do here
what did you learn from working with the
seattle seahawks about coping with
intense emotions it's a very intense
sport they've been to the absolute top
of it
that's something i think as well that
people wish that they had more capacity
with something very intense happens and
they want to be able to deal with it
yeah um
you know like being there
i was with the team for nine years and
we had to win a super bowl and
lose a super bowl both dramatic
both amazing
and um
emotions are
let's start the kind of at the top like
emotions are
one of the very special parts of being
human
there's a difference between emotions
and feelings right so emotions are the
physiological structure
of the way that you interpret something
and feelings is the way that those
physiological
[Music]
experiences are
take place so the feeling of something
and the emotions are related but
separate
and it's it's a unique quality that we
have as humans
to have this part of our experience
be absolutely
germane and we're not very good at it
especially like the sandbox i grew up in
was like hey suck it up kid
you know like
are you crying you're not crying are you
what do you do what
come on get it together dude you know
like it was like a different sandbox
than
the way that i want to play now which is
like yeah i'm [ __ ] feeling it what
what's the problem you know like i want
to feel everything
with my wife with my son with my
coworkers with my partners like i want
to feel everything i don't want to just
be
happy
i i mean do you want anything of like
just to be muted because we got a range
of emotions and happy is just one
and
so when you ask about that
the the idea was to
at the seattle seahawks
is to invest in their inner life
so that we have range
and when you know you have range
you can go freely into all environments
and so if you don't have range well like
i don't have range in
basketball i played you know a little
bit here and there whatever but
if i'm gonna go
ucla is known for one of the
universities in the states they're known
for great pickup basketball games in the
summer
um great and you know like stephen curry
and and and show up in this gym and i
don't know if stefan is still playing
there but like greats would show up and
play
i don't have that range i can't just hey
give me the rock like but i might be
able to go to a local place and play
some pickup but i don't have the range
to go freely but what's wonderful about
psychology is that
when you invest you can go freely
anywhere and most people don't have that
range so much so that they show we show
up to a dinner party and we're nervous
we show up to give a speech god help us
it's the number one fear for humans
why would giving a speech be so
dangerous
what do you think chris well i think
ancestrally it's because if you were to
perform in front of the tribe and you
were to mess up
that would lower your standing status is
one of the key
uh indicators of your success for
reproduction and survival if you do
something stupid in front of the
chieftain and 50 people around the
campfire then you look dumb i think
that's why it's wide into us
amen and
if you get kicked out of that tribe we
got problems right you know and so
that
it's the modern day saber-too tiger if
you will is what other people will think
of us
fear of people's opinions
as we call it and so fopo is like the
number one constrictor of one's
potential
it's easy to work with do you think do
you think that it's fear of other
people's opinions as opposed to fears of
insufficiency that come from internals
yeah
yeah i think we externalize it uh i
think that internal
game that we're playing that we're not
enough
is built on it not enough
based on what full who
yeah right and so
this moment right now is all
what we get you and me like is it
it's pretty good
it's fun you're creating space to to
play you know like this is good and so
if i'm performing for you then i've
probably got problems like
and there's a chance that you run the
risk of not being good enough by your
judgment or i run the chance of that but
i think that's the game most people are
playing most of the time
and so
because it's hardwired our ancient brain
is trying to survive
and modern day stressors are different
than the ancient stressors when the
brain was forming and it hasn't changed
much the brain
but modern-day environmental conditions
have changed dramatically so that we're
playing an old game we still have the
same stress response to the saber-tooth
tiger or to the chieftain that might
kick us out of the tribe and will end up
being homeless to
giving a presentation at work that
almost everybody in the room doesn't
want to be there for in any case
exactly that's the problem it's the
ancient brain's response to a modern
stressor unfit for purpose as it's
called yeah there you go unfit for
purpose what does that mean i've never
heard it so it's just a misalignment
right between it's adam hart's book on
fit for purpose which was about how
we're male adapted for the modern world
uh anything the type of normal stimuli
right so you know dopamine system great
really good tells us that we need to go
and get things dopamine system plus
the world's best algorithms and the
phone in our pocket perhaps not so good
you know
hunger pangs great means that we don't
run out of fuel hunger pangs plus
uh auramorphically designed perfect
fries from
mcdonald's not so good because these
obesity epidemics and stuff like that
you do you do have these um
misalignments between what we're built
for and what's happening um one of the
things that i think
that i really appreciate about your work
is the um
bifurcation between experiencing
something emotion
and what that means to us and how we
interpret it and how it impacts our
story about ourselves thought patterns
performance all of that sort of stuff
can you explain your um philosophy
around this around
separating out what it is that our
emotions tell us from how it impacts us
and the way that we actually show up
yeah i think they thank you and the
sensitivity is not necessarily
separating them out but we can try to
decouple them for
clarity right now but
let me let me slightly pivot it to to
this idea which is
it's going to hopefully relate to ideas
is this idea that we need to
do more
to be more we need to do the
extraordinary to be extraordinary
and that's a model that many of us have
swallowed
and best in the world are waving their
arms saying
i need to be more
be more present be more authentic be
more grounded be more creative
be more and let the doing flow from that
place
and if i have that alignment then
then it fundamentally flips the whole
thing and so
you're so that's a framework that
introduced to answer your question which
is
um
the way that we
experience
anything
is fundamentally
related to the way that we think about
ourselves our future and the experience
now who's responsible for that
i am you are you know for your own
experience
and
if you can get
clear on how you want to experience
anything
the whole game gets easy like honestly
it gets
you know like so often we are unclear
and then unskilled
so somebody cuts us off
and we respond okay well that response
that you have
for me
that response that i have if it's like a
fight or flight is a great moment to go
oh
look i'm down in the animal part of my
brain like what is happening well i'm
pissed off about this that or that okay
so this is my thinking pattern
as well as the alertness required to
have to potentially swerve
okay so just because i've got this
alertness on that i need to swerve does
that mean i should now automatically go
into anger let me flip somebody off
because we don't know if they're late
for grandma's funeral we don't know
what's up so you know it's like using
your internal cues
to be able to better understand how to
be more present how to be less a b and c
and more
abn d e and f i guess and then if we can
be more
and let the doing flow from that
orientation
i'm going to say this again that too is
part of mastery
i had a uh
weird run-in anger is an emotion that i
very very rarely feel right um for
whatever reason that might be i had a
really weird run-in about a month ago
and it i i got angry and it's such a
bizarre emotion it's kind of like to me
it felt a lot like um eating a food that
i've maybe only tasted
a few times in my life so i've got this
emotion that arised inside of me and i
was like holy [ __ ]
like this is what anger feels oh this is
what whatever tastes like sriracha or
some [ __ ] this is like what this is what
it feels like
and uh
and
that was
the point i'm making is curiosity to me
seems to be such a solution to a lot of
this and this may be me retrofitting
something that i find is a solution to a
lot of problems curiosity just getting
interested in what the outcome might be
um
but
a lot of my friends that i know who are
curious and who are genuinely interested
in what might be on the other side of
something they have an impending breakup
it sucks i don't want to this is going
to be an awkward situation whatever for
me and whoever i'm with for a while
but i'm genuinely interested to see what
it's like to experience these emotions
and i think that this is what you were
saying which is if you restrict yourself
to just happiness or whatever that's
like restricting yourself to just one
food type you know not every food type
might be good like people eat hot food
that's not not necessarily great i don't
know how far i can take the food analogy
but my point is that
the
the range of experience that you have
the opportunity that you have to
experience all of these things
in retrospect is going to be beautiful
the more broad that it is and the more
three-dimensional that it is and
i think getting genuinely interested and
curious about how it is to experience
all that stuff is a pretty good fix for
a lot of things
i'm nodding my head like grinning like
yeah i mean 100 so wherever your
mentorship of that idea took place
you know maybe go back and thank them
because that is
um the unlock that's the key hole to be
able to
in a healthy way detach but not be aloof
but to be curious and watch and
there is there's
there's an art to this though
which is
if you're
constantly just being curious of the
experience and not actually experiencing
it
then
it's a mechanism to save yourself and
provide distance from the intensity of
that heat or that emotion
and so people around you won't
really know you because you're not in it
in a way you're observing like the
researcher you're not actually part of
the experiment
and so there it's materially important
to not be the mountaintop
observer but to be down in the city as
well so there's times we want to observe
and be curious and there's times where
like hey [ __ ] let's go and so it's
having both of those things
um
[Music]
as a uh what's the word i'm looking for
i want to say like as a recipe but it's
not quite it's being able to do both of
those that's materially important and it
sounds like your history you've got a
history of mindfulness
yeah i just
spent a lot of time doing it which is
great and i've said my friend corey
allen
12th ever episode that i did on this
show
he
used the term called the he calls the
mindfulness gap which is the best way
that i've described it a brief beat in
between stimulus and response call it
whatever it is that you want to call it
if all that i ever get out of
mindfulness training is the fact that
i've got a mindfulness gap
the thousand sessions plus that i've
done have been completely worth it the
fact that something happens
and i'm not at the mercy of my
programming
around how i respond to it now i might
be after a beat but i get to glimpse the
brief
interlude right between the two um what
you just said is very very interesting
the fact that
is it as good as the mindfulness gap no
no nothing's as good as that corey corey
you won um
what you said was that
people who get curious about the process
people who are um introspective who do
self-work who are
interested in their own internal
experience right
that can come that can become its own
crooks a little bit that can become its
own problem
because it takes you out of experiencing
the moment and this flows forward into
people who can't get out of their own
heads when they perform
that
i think there is a tension between
cognition and intuition right
i'm thinking about the thing i'm feeling
doing a thing
how can people pull themselves out of
cognition and more into intuition or
presence or whatever you would say
i think you're i think we're talking i
think the answer is
exactly what you would imagine it to be
is
it's a issue of
courage to feel the thing and the
courage is because you might unravel
you know and that takes
that vulnerability of unraveling as is
um you know back to the ancient brain
like there's a cost to that and there's
also
a gift which is like oh well there's a
limit
okay
um and so it's the courage to go in
and kind of
shove the oars if you will into inside
the boat and be like i i gotta ride this
and
the fact that you like
you know turn it for just a moment that
you didn't know anger and i i i was like
wow how does that happen
you know that you wouldn't know anger
like i i wanted to go back to that like
how do you not know anger
or not know it well like
i think you would have an unlock here
that i'd love to learn from so i say
vulnerability like you got to go for
that courage and then how would you how
would you answer it
so
the reason i think anger doesn't seem to
come up for me is that it
it gets split off into other types of
emotions
so um
self-blame
uh would probably be one of those that
would come in so you know anger might
something that might make somebody else
angry i would probably end up um maybe
feeling self-resentment for i would be
like look he could have done would have
done should have done better than that
at whatever this thing is that's why
it's your fault uh and i'm working with
my current coach vinnie on um
where that voice comes from right like
what is it yeah so that would be
actually a
a cousin to external anger
you know internal anger would kind of
have the same velocity but you're it's a
slight cousin to it which is like wow
you should have
you know what is wrong with you like
jesus is that is that really all you got
you know so it's not like an
aggressiveness in anger but it is still
going to hang yes yes so that would be
that's one way and i mean this there's
probably you know it's one mechanism
that i've maybe managed to identify and
there's there's probably like a million
a million more that i'm totally unaware
of
but it is interesting
to think that and i was talking to a
friend i was playing disc golf the other
day it turns out dude have you ever seen
how seriously people take disc golf
it is
insane they've got caddies they've got
one of those roll along things with a
million different discs in it so i'm
playing disc golf in austin with my with
my friend
and we were talking about this and he
said that anger is an emotion that he
feels
fairly rarely as well
and it just blows my mind that we could
go through life having
kind of like a set of blinkers on one
side of the human experience and that
there's this bit
over there that we don't really tend to
see or that we we transmute it into
something else self-blame right you know
or self-doubt or
unhappiness or whatever um it's
fascinating
yeah i think it's i think it's a great
place to explore because
um
we
anger is a secondary emotion so one of
the things i
work on i i only have a couple clients i
work on or work with a month
and then the rest is like the
the beautiful science of psychology at
scale right to try to
move as many people that want to be
moved
and so
when i'm working with the individual
one of the things that we must spend
time on is how do emotions work
for you and if we're gonna limit one of
the core primary ones we got problems
but but anger is secondary
it's not a primary emotion
so it comes in response to either
something
around fear or something around sadness
so when you're hurt that's like on a
sadness scale somewhere and if you're
scared or afraid something there those
are so
difficult to deal with and anger so much
easier so at some level you're you might
be working at the primary level
but if you're if you've got that funny
little offshoot around
the subtleness of turning that anger
inward
then it then i would recommend that you
go into the fearness of it or the
sadness of it and explore those uh at
tilt
and um
you might find that
you want to do anger more you can get
this better outlet here yeah are you
writing am i right and saying is it
fear sadness disgust
something else something else is that
the primary ones or is this a different
model that you're looking at yeah no
there's
early research was um
yes
seven or eight and then
we're starting to find this like
256 emotions and so i make it really
simple i say four
so i go okay and this is part of the
work right like
like let me ask you what would be the
four primary emotions if you had four
scales
and each scale you could go up five and
down five so a scale of ten and the up
five would be like the most of that
thing and the down five would be the
least but it still hangs on that same
scale
well if you've said
uh
sadness on one end i have to presume
that there's got to be an opposite to
that so something like happiness on the
other hand so sadness is a scale and put
that at a five and then a ten would be
like grief depression you know way up
there right yes and then happiness good
that's the second scale third is
uh anger no sorry no anger you just said
um
yeah fear and anger those are the four
okay yes what do we do with disgust what
do we do with um
shame what do we do with guilt yeah and
what do we do with surprise
so
but i just make it super simple the
thing is as well sorry those ones that
was based on wasn't it based on facial
expressions that as well and you think
well okay like i
maybe the way that my face can be broken
down is useful but from a performance
perspective like my my feelings are on
disgust i don't imagine that disgust
plays a huge role in performance no yeah
that's why i spend most of my time with
on the basic four
and then let's be really good there
this be great at at being able to
toggle up and down having levers and
dials for those four
and let's even be better at knowing the
thoughts that precede those emotions or
if you if you come late to the game and
you're just aware of that emotion how
would you want to work with the the
second beat which is the thought so it's
this game between thoughts and emotions
and environment and let's just be great
at being able to have great awareness
and
incredible skills around those three
what's the future of performance
psychology for you if you could predict
the next
10 to 20 years there's going to be a
swing
to um
[Music]
it's happening now there's a swing to it
which is awesome i mean there's an
incredible investment and
it's going to get confusing
you know at scale because there's all
types of range of skill around from
scientists and practitioners around
you know how to invest from a
psychological perspective for humans
and then we're going to try to
technologicalize it
technical of what's the word whatever
that is we're going to probably put
technology around it
which will be good in an advancement
we're going to see as a third
string to this we're going to see vr
come online in an important way around
emotions
and it's going to return also back to
some ancient roots so we're going to
modern science
we're going to and there's going to be
some
interesting outreach to that there's
going to be
um
range of investment of what psychology
really looks like and then we're going
to have some ancient traditions come
come back online so what the future
looks like um bright
and big
and a seat at the table for
human potential
and i think that it's going to be an
exciting time for people to invest in
this part of their life and so
relationships are going to get better
with self with others with the planet
and if we don't get those three right
we're going to have a shitty experience
here on the earth and then the last is
relationships with machines
so that's at the center of
the purpose of the company that um that
i'm working to build is building those
relationships with all four of those
we're gonna have the smartest machine
smarter than the smartest human in nine
years
and so if we treat that thing like
like another if we treat it like it's
going to
take over and we're afraid of it and we
don't properly nurture the relationships
eq is going to be solvable
at some point for machines if we don't
have the right relationship with that
and they are that much smarter
they understand intelligence from both
emotional and uh cognition
you know we got problems
and so we'll see we'll see how this goes
michael gervais ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you do where should they go
first thank you for creating the space
chris very cool i i haven't kind of
blabbed about this much of
you know my stuff for a long time so
thank you um
funnymastery.net that would be the place
to go check out like what we're trying
to what we're trying to do for
psychology at scale um you can also all
of
all of the
social handles are at
michael gervais
g-e-r-v-a-i-s
dude i appreciate you thank you
thank you chris what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you